We've been wondering whether Barack Obama
will endorse one of the Democratic primary
candidates for 2020, uh, maybe his former
vice president Biden before the primary is
over.
And it's not clear that Barack Obama is going
to get involved in this primary, but we now
have heard from Trump's former advisor, Valerie
Jarrett, who says that number one, Barack
Obama, his quote, very concerned about what
is going on in the United States, read Trump,
uh, and that he will be getting involved in
the 2020 campaign in some form with the goal
of ultimately defeating the president, Donald
Trump.
Um, the, let's assume she's right.
Okay.
So we're saying this is what Valerie Jarrett
has said.
President Obama thinks, and we'll do, and
I can't imagine she would speak without knowing
that for a fact.
So let's imagine that it's true for the purposes
of our discussion today.
Um, it appears as though Barack Obama does
not plan on getting involved in the primary.
And my thought is that this is the right decision.
And I'm going to tell you why.
I'm guessing Barack Obama understands.
And everybody around Barack Obama understands,
realizes that there's very little upside longterm
for Democrats of Barack Obama getting involved
in the primary.
Now this is not, why didn't Elizabeth Warren
endorsed Bernie during the primary?
If she liked him so much, Obama's relationship
to the presidency and candidates is very different
than that of Elizabeth Warren's number one.
Uh, Barack Obama was president of the United
States.
Number two, one of the current Democratic
primary candidates is Barack Obama's former
vice president.
So I see this as a no win for Barack Obama
to get involved in the primary.
If Obama comes out and endorses Joe Biden,
it furthers the DNC establishment narrative.
It opens up the door to more claims of an
unbalanced primary in which the DNC or quote
establishment Democrats are meddling.
And whether it's true or not, a former president
saying that he wants his former VP to be the
nominee, the election right after the DNC
screwed Bernie in favor of Hillary.
It doesn't look good.
So whatever gain might be calculated for Barack
Obama to come out now and endorse Joe Biden,
I think has far more negatives outweighing
it.
If Obama not, uh, endorses Biden during the
primary and Biden does not get the nomination,
then there's the question of whether Barack
Obama has weakened the power of his endorsement
by initially endorsing somebody who doesn't
win.
And then having to go out and campaign for
somebody that he didn't endorse during the
primary.
If instead of Joe Biden, uh, Barack Obama
prefers somebody else, imagine that Barack
Obama Prefers Bernie Sanders or Elizabeth
Warren or whoever and he endorses them during
the primary and Biden ends up winning.
Who is of course leading in the polls right
now it's the same problem in reverse.
How strong is Obama Supportive Biden as the
nominee?
If Obama supported Sanders during the primary,
and I understand that many politicians endorse
one person during the primary, that person
loses, then they support somebody else.
It is different when you are a former president
and it is different when one of the candidates
is your former vice president.
So to me this is fine.
Okay, support who you like in the primary
and then you vote to defeat Trump no matter
who the nominee is from the people that are
running.
But the perception of it not going right for
Barack Obama wouldn't be good.
President Obama, imagine that he has built
up a sort of specific amount of political
capital.
It's a lot.
Okay.
The former president who is seen very favorably
by Americans, has a lot of political capital,
but it's not unlimited political capital.
And I don't believe that there is a long term
gain for Barack Obama to get involved in the
primary, in the context of working to defeat
Donald Trump, which is the goal, what Obama
should do during the primary.
It's two things.
Number one, demand and lobby for an open,
transparent primary to the extent that he's
willing to do that.
And it may not be a significant extent and
I understand that.
And number two, Barack Obama during the primary
should be working to push back against all
of the voter suppression efforts from Republicans
to ensure that when the time comes to vote
in November of 2020, every vote is counted.
Everyone who wants to vote gets to vote and
have their votes counted, which will help
the eventual democratic nominee.
When the time comes for the DNC to formally
nominate the winner of the primary at the
convention, Barack Obama should be there introducing
them and speaking at the DNC and rallying
the troops.
Uh, but there is not an advantage to him getting
involved at this point in the primary endorsing
somebody.
Now there are some really low energy Beta
comments from Republicans saying that it's
unbecoming of a president, a former president,
to get involved at all in the presidential
race and that it looks bad.
Gimme a break.
Okay, you're pathetic.
It's unbecoming.
To have a president like Trump, embarrassing
the country day in and day out on the national
stage.
Barack Obama is concerned about the future
of this country and he wants to work to change
that trajectory.
Or at least according to Valerie Jarrett,
he's planning on working to change that and
he should be applauded for it.
But I completely understand why Barack Obama
is not likely to get involved in this primary.
And I actually agree with that decision for
the strategic reasons that I've outlined.
If you disagree with my conclusion or if you
simply disagree
with how I built up that conclusion.
I want to hear from, I'm on Twitter at the
pacman and the show is on Twitter
at
David Pakman show,